Jim Valcourt:
We're here at the Princeton Pre-rade, where we welcome the incoming freshman class of
2014 for the first time. Could you describe the tradition that's going on here, the Pre-rade? What's this all about?
Will Manning:
Well, the tradition of the Pre-rade is about welcoming the incoming freshmen, because when
they walk in the gate, it's like they are walking into the student body.
[crowd noise, cheers, drums]
Jim Valcourt:
So, what is the FitzRandolph Gate superstition?
Maraiya Hakeem:
The superstition is that once you come through the middle of the gate, until you graduate,
do not go back through the middle of the gate or you will not graduate.
Jim Valcourt:
And do you believe that?
Maraiya Hakeem:
I don't know if I believe it, but I have not walked through the middle of the gate just
in case it actually is true.
Jim Valcourt:
What would it take to get you to walk through the gate?
Maraiya Hakeem:
Absolutely nothing. I was going to say $5 million, but even at that I think I need the
Princeton degree even more than $5 million right now.
Will Manning:
In like a million, billion years, it would not be worth it.
Jim Valcourt:
So, free T-shirts, lets talk about those. About how many free T-shirts would you say
you have from your time at Princeton?
Will Manning:
At least 30.
student:
I probably have at least 20 or so piled up.
Demetrius Lewis:
I've got at least 10 or 11 at home.
Jim Valcourt:
So, if you had to use all of your T-shirts for some creative use, like if you took them
to a desert island, what would you do with the T-shirts?
Demetrius Lewis:
I could probably make a tent out of them, since I have so many.
Jim Valcourt:
And you could live off those, not have to do laundry for a while?
Demetrius Lewis:
Exactly, no laundry needed when you have free T-shirts coming at you.
[crowd noise]
Jim Valcourt:
What do you think of the Princeton squirrels?
Stacey Menjivar:
I've seen the squirrels. They are really aggressive. When they come in my way, I move and change
paths. I don't wait for them to move.
student:
They are vicious here. They are not scared of people.
I've seen them plotting. I'm very concerned.
David Drew:
I've been very impressed by the squirrels. I've seen a couple of really, really large ones.
I saw one on its hind legs that marked on me.
Jim Valcourt:
Has it attacked you?
David Drew:
Not quite yet, but I felt threatened.
Jim Valcourt:
Do you have any words of advice for the freshmen class?
Maraiya Hakeem:
I would say to go to many shows, talk to many people and try things out. If you don't like
it, move on to something else. Just make sure you actually go out to events and see what
Maraiya Hakeem:
the community has to offer.
Jarett Schwartz:
Advice in three words? Explore, study and study!
Will Manning:
Don't freaking procrastinate!!
Demetrius Lewis:
That's about it. Enjoy your time here. There is nothing else like it. Have a good time,
and enjoy yourself.
Jim Valcourt:
Any last, final words for the freshmen?
student:
Watch out for the squirrels!
[music]
[locomotive chant]